foreign
the courage that it takes to tackle
situations While others flee is exactly
the Courage the London fire brigade
commissioner believes that they all need
to show to face down the misogyny racism
and bullying within the service
I'll turn back to the report that's 2
000 of our own staff who've written this
report you know and it's not just
black firefighters it's not just women
this is white firefighters it's our
lgbtq plus staff it's the neurodiverse
it's the quiet people you know people
have made their voice heard here within
the London fire brigade and they are
asking for change so I think there's
very many people across the Brigade who
will be like me appalled horrified by
this report but will recognize it and I
hope we'll see it as an opportunity for
sea change
after the grenfell fire their
operational failings were laid bare but
this is something deeper
includes a black firefighter who found a
noose above his locker just one of many
shocking episodes the London mayor
described the findings as a borrowance
but has backed commissioner Andy Rowe to
stay in his job and lead the change
Sadiq Khan said we both agree that all
of its recommendations and findings must
be acted upon with urgency and
conviction to rebuild public trust and
the confidence of lfb staff and
firefighters who have been failed for
far too long
please show me your hands the police
have had body-worn cameras for years and
they'll now be rolled out within London
fire brigade to improve public Trust
cases of abuse in the service will be
externally investigated and firefighters
who have crossed the line could well be
sacked what we found specifically about
women I think to my mind uh there hasn't
been an institution that has found
itself to be institutionally misogynist
so this is the first of its kind and
what we found was that pretty much every
woman we interviewed and there are
hundreds of them complained of sexism
and abuse
he calls for the majority of good
professional firefighters to work with
their management to root out these
cultures that exist in London but also
the report concludes in other parts of
the UK's fire service
Tom Parmenter Sky News